all right good morning everyone welcome
to the simon's institute my name is
peter bartlett i'm the associate
director here i'm very happy to have you
here for this
uh final workshop from in the causality
program so we're a collaborative
research institute in theoretical
computer science we run these uh
semester-long programs two
each semester and causality is one of
the two this semester
um very happy to have it running a big
thank you to the nsf for his support of
the program through fodzy
the program brings around 90 long-term
visitors to berkeley
in total
and has a bunch of these activities this
is the last workshop of the program
quantum physics and statistical causal
models
let me start with a big thank you to the
organizers thomas richardson and
frederick eberhardt
thanks for putting together a great
great program for this week i'll hand
over to tom to introduce the workshop in
a moment i wanted to say a few words
about logistics so you've discovered the
food and coffee outside you'll have that
during breaks
please don't bring that inside water is
fine but we try to keep the auditorium
clean um
for lunches you're going to be on your
own there are plenty of options and uh
you know follow a local or a long-term
participant if you if you need some
advice
um masks indoors are recommended but not
mandatory uh right now
at lunch time if you want to leave
things or anytime i guess if you want to
leave things in
in the building there are lockers on the
far side of the building at on this
level
that work with a pin code
and we've got a hybrid format so we're
we're using
zoom uh omid far as our videographer and
he'll be helping all the speakers hook
up their computers and and set up
microphones
uh and finally a big thank you to um
ashley hassan who's at the back and
kelani pendland for all the local
arrangements for this workshop
[Applause]
thank you so i'm going to keep this
short we're already
running a little behind so uh welcome
thank you for coming and i know we're
still at a point where
it's a real commitment to
come here
uh in person and you know also to all of
those who are watching at home
uh thank you for participating and uh
yeah i i think all that all i really
want to say is that
um i was very excited at the prospect of
putting this um having a workshop on
this topic because um
yeah i've been aware for some time that
there are interesting synergies but
there are um
uh
people in different fields thinking
about very similar and related problems
and i think that we'll see that in the
talks that take place in the workshop
and i would also like to thank the symes
institute for uh for
for putting this uh allowing us to have
this workshop and also for the
semester-long program on causality which
has been a great success um and i think
without further ado i will pass over to
robin to introduce the first speaker
thank you very much
okay so our first speaker today is ellie
wolfe who is a research scientist at
perimeter institute in waterloo canada
and he has interests in
self-test of physical theories but today
he's going to be talking about
applications of the inflation technique
for causal inference
thank you very much uh it's really
exciting for me to be here this is not
just a great workshop that any workshop
is a great opportunity to travel this in
particular i think is a meeting of
fields which is long overdue one that
i'm really excited about and i have not
felt like i'm going to learn something
from attending a workshop to the extent
that i'm excited about this workshop in
a very very very long time um so thank
you thompson and your guys is really
excellent um
so i wanted to talk about um the
inflation technique which is some
material i came up with my uh
colleagues to
test causal compatibility if we have a
causal structure it's a hypothesis can't
explain our data so we have some methods
to do so um i'm gonna introduce it but
it did come out like four years ago or
something so i'm going to introduce it
fairly quickly and spend most of my talk
on
what happens when it gets hard
but let's take a slow in the beginning
so
physicists came to study causal
inference
by way of bell's theorem bell's theorem
is from 1964. it's a result in quantum
physics which says that if we make
certain assumptions about nature of
reality such as um influences not
propagating fast in the speed of light
such as
the possibility of free choice
then modular there's assumptions the
predictions of quantum physics cannot be
classically explained
so it appears to be a really exciting
result in
foundations of physics or in philosophy
but what does it have to do with causal
inference
and one way of understanding it is to
say oh well bell wasn't using the
language but it's actually
a statement about causal structures so
here we call this the bell dag directed
acyclic graph
i've denoted a and b as variables which
represent the outcomes of quantum
measurements if you're familiar with
bell's original experiment x and y would
be sort of the settings um
and there's a hidden common cause which
could potentially lead to correlation in
a and b
and um this codifies
the cumulative set of assumptions that
went into bell's theorem like freedom of
choice what is freedom of choice it
means that the experimentalist who is
you know about to do some quantum
experiment can choose some
setting an apparatus and that that
setting is in fact not dependent on
anything else in the causal plastic
universe not dependent on sort of like
the initial state of the universe which
might have sort of like some giant
quantum state which
predetermines how the experimentalist is
thinking as well as the results of
experiment and so we just denoted by
that by saying oh look the variable x it
doesn't have anything in the calls past
it's independent of everything else
that's just a way of codifying free
choice which is a philosophical
assumption with causal language
so if we take those assumptions and we
express them all in this causal diagram
then this is the idea of classically
explaining a quantum experiment if these
statistics that we would generate from a
and b and x and y are compatible with
this causal structure then great
everything works the way that we expect
and if not then one of the assumptions
is wrong and how you choose to interpret
that
there's disagreements in the camp among
physicists
but just preliminarily
if we make an assumption about causal
structure and we want to sort of test
and falsify is it a valid explanation
we'll notice that
there are equality constraints and
inequality constraints so an example of
an
inequality constraint is a bell
inequality and so here i've written it
with a less than or equal to sign but we
also have equality constraints which
physicists would call like no signal
inequalities and that might tell you
that um
uh if you take the the value of b and
you fix a particular y so you're looking
at
the instance of b when y was set to some
value
b do y as it were
that this is a well-defined variable
and
it is well defined in the sense that it
doesn't depend on the variable x so if
you do this experiment and you
toggle x to different settings
you should not see that the distribution
over the variable b should change
right that is a constraint it's an
equality constraint
um now some of these uh are going to be
uh
the things that we're going to end up
violating when we actually move beyond
classical physics um but the the idea um
that we've endorsed here at perimeter or
not here at perimeter but at perimeter
is
that when the quantum experiment
is not explained by the data not
necessarily when the data is not
explained by such a causal hypothesis we
have to throw it out we say this is not
a valid explanation so there's drake the
canadian rapper saying it's not
acceptable what is the version that is
good um so we might uh if you were in
sort of different camps posit maybe
there is super luminal influence or
things like that but for now i'll just
assume that we're just working in um
a broader notion of a common cause so
the idea of a latent variable is just
sort of usually a random variable that
we just don't see its value
and so if we're going to do things
quantumly we're no longer going to make
that assumption we're going to say that
there's a possibility of random
variables being common cause connected
but not by way of a classical hidden
random variable we would call it sort of
like a quantum hidden random variable if
you would like or quantum entanglement
and that's
these are sort of the same structure but
with different assumptions about the
nature of the hidden variables um and it
leads to different predictions so
are yeah
and just
yes in your interpretation while you
were explaining this first inequality
i want really to understand why this
inequality is derived is because
you have an inequality because you have
a range of magnitude where you could
detect the violation or
why it is not exactly an equality and
then you get that inequality
so i'm not talking about
a particular experiment per se i'm
talking about the set of
all data that could be explained if the
classical assumptions were true so it
turns out that the quantum data is not
going to fit at all but if we just said
what are the sort of statistics
that we might ever see right so the
probability of a
the probability of a could be 0.8
it could also be 0.2 so already we have
the possibility of an inequality there
because the probability of a taking the
value 0 is somewhere
greater than or equal to 0 and somewhere
and less than or equal to 1. these are
our trivial inequalities in a sense but
they are inequalities so the set of
statistics that are compatible defines a
um
a volume and so if it's if it's not a
point if it's a volume of statistics
there's going to be inequalities
involved i see i i i i got that my
intuition was like to try to understand
how this is was related to your
intuition of moving
in the in the experiment of moving that
wide
um yeah at the end the inequality is not
um uh that's more sort of the equality
but let's talk about that afterwards
all right so
um one of things that uh
i have been motivated to do is to try to
understand
what are the predictions
what are the constraints that are
classically implied if we assume that
the bell structure is everything's going
the way it usually is that if we move to
quantum physics these constraints can be
violated right because not everything
can be um
in fact if we look at these two
hypotheses and we say what are their
testable implications so we've said that
they imply equality's inequalities the
equality constraints that are implied by
both of these two competing hypotheses
agree
the where they differ potentially is in
some of their inequalities and it's some
not all so here is an example of an
inequality and you can see there it has
the upper bound of zero here it has a
upper bound which is strictly larger
than zero um and so this is sort of like
where we can go and see the difference
um
and
finding these sort of inequalities is
fun because it lets us
validate that in fact we're dealing with
quantum stuff
so that's like the self-testing of a fun
experiment we get to actually know oh
yes we were doing quantum things
um so just a little recap in terms of
what is known
all of the conditional independence
relations which are implied by a given
causal hypothesis the separation leads
to conditional dependence yeah
over the observed variables all
conditional defenses over the observed
variables hold classically yep so that's
sort of like the uh ordinary markov
property
in fact the nested of property also
holds
so these are
in succinct if there's an equality
constraint which is implied by the
classical version of the hypothesis then
when you make a quantum version of said
hypothesis the equality constraints are
still there so if you ever hope to say
oh look this is how i'm going to prove
that i'm in fact dealing with quantum
weirdness don't use the equality
constraints because they're not going to
be quantum viable you need to go to the
inequality constraints
so only the inequalities matter so how
do we find inequalities which admit
quantum violation we're going to get to
that in great depth over the course of
this talk but here is an example of a
famous uh called structure it's very
simple the instrumental scenario
it has inequalities such as
this which is the bonai inequality
and
many uh people who are not physicists
probably have just seen it with the
value of two on the other side um and
this is an inequality which holds if
you're
explained uh by the instrument scenario
but if we make things go quantum it can
be violated on the other hand there are
other inequalities also valid for this
scenario like pearl's instrumental
inequality where it's not viable so we
have this difference between like pearls
inequality and bones inequality pearls
is not quantum viable bones inequality
is quantum viable
so we're trying to understand that yeah
okay
so let's try to uh now
go to inflation because that's the topic
yeah
i just i'm having a fancy i'm having a
little hard time tracking because this
isn't the language
i don't use it good but i i just want to
ask technically yes it's basically what
you're doing when you have these three
values in one case you're you're
imposing uh no signaling and
and in the other case you're not
um no l doesn't talk about
you know really was thinking if i have
to introduce the whole quantum formalism
and the first talk it sucks so i tried
to like skip all this because that's the
hard question um but no i i am actually
assuming that no signaling goes through
entirely what i have not put on the
board is a description of if
uh we wanted to describe the set of
quantum
models
like we could write an equation with
some
quantifiers that we could eliminate um
and it would be those that were trying
that would lead to this value like if we
optimized over a set of quantum models
um but no signaling would continue to
hold
yeah that's rubble
i'm sorry that's what i'm trying to
understand right i i think of this just
in terms of locality okay you put a
locality constraint on the arrows
and then you get bells in equality
now you put a little like
you know green
glowy thing and and all of a sudden that
was supposed to change and i'm just
trying to understand
if i just put a regular arrow between
the two sides then i can violate
signaling as well
right so i'm trying to understand one of
the things you're holding fixed is no
signaling right
or not
yes no signaling and is an equality
constraint and it is held fixed
particularly let's go through that
yes
no signaling continues to hold when i
assume that we get to do quantum effects
so this is a matter of some
interpretation perhaps
but if you interpret bell's theorem as
uh indicating
the possibility of signaling or hidden
signaling
um
then uh you would be using sort of a
different quantum formulas and why i'm
using um i'm taking um that
if we
take
uh
my interpretation of quantum mechanics
then
the quantum explanation behind a bell
inequality violation
um
does not allow for signaling no matter
what you do
yeah really quick what does gpt stand
for generalized probabilistic theories
um um so uh
quantum theory is sort of like an
example of where classical assumptions
break down and then we can consider a a
broader set um and so throughout this
talk um i'm going to say like oh it's
quantum valid it's quantum non-valid and
i'm really going to not be
distinguishing quantum and gpt because
nothing i'm going to say is very
particular to quantum physics as opposed
to more generalized physical theories
all right so let me introduce inflation
really quickly
this is the triangle scenario which is
sort of what
motivated us to
come up with inflation at all
and so this is a
causal hypothesis over three observed
variables
with three hidden variables
and so every pair of observed variables
is common cause connected by a hidden
variable um so what uh would it mean for
a distribution number a and b and c to
be compatible with this hypothesis it
would mean that for every uh probability
of joint probability of a and b and z it
would factorize uh like so so they'd be
sort of like
the distributions over the three hidden
variables um and response functions for
each
observed variable on its parents
so how do we test right without actually
trying to find uh hidden variables
whether or not a given distribution is
possible so the idea of inflation is to
assume that
it's a valid explanation assume that uh
our our distribution did arise in the
triangle in this case um and then uh
follow implications of that assumption
until they lead to a contradiction
so we start by saying all right if um
i had some possible way of explaining my
data in the original graph that means
there is some distribution over the uh
hidden variables and some response
functions which give rise to this then
there's sort of a duncan experiment that
could do like uh you can think of it as
a static ground i could create an
independent and identically distributed
version of this ca common cause i don't
know what it is but i could create
another copy of it
and then i could
take this hidden variable which is
currently being distributed to a and b
and i'll send
another copy of it off to another
version of it
right and so now
i have a
a distribution number four observed
variables a1 a2 b and c
and
assuming that i in fact recycle the
causal parameters correctly so that this
is distributed the same way as this and
that a depends on its two parents a2 the
same way that a1 depends on its two
parents which is the same way that a
originally dependent on its parents then
we have some implications so we have the
original graph of where you see the
inflation graph over a1 a2 and bc
um and we're going to see sort of like
what happens so um i want you to sort of
follow these three steps which is uh how
inflation works we imagine the inflation
graph which i just drew we're going to
then express certain monomials of
probabilities in the original graph as
marginals of the inflation graph which
i'll walk through and we'll note that
the inflation graph also implies some
symmetry constraints on its own
distributions which come from the
assumption of recycling causal
parameters and when we put those
together we get sort of a linear program
which gives us constraints so first
let's try to express monomials in the
original graph we have abc is there
anywhere where we can say oh the
distribution over abc and the original
graph is recapitulated in the inflation
path and it is it's just a1 bc because
it's just the same subgraph so far so
good
and this is sort of a really simple way
of saying i found some monomial of
probabilities in my original graph it's
just the whole original joint
distribution and i can express it as
some marginal of the inflation graph
because here i've traced out a2
but there are others
so for example i could take a monomial
which is the probability of a times the
probability of c in my original graph
can i express that as a marginal
somewhere in my inflation graph well yes
because if i trace out a and b and i
look at just the marginal of a2 and c
they have no
uh causal ancestors in common right c
depends on these which are roots a2
depends on these that your root so
therefore
a2 and c in the inflation graph should
factorize
of course the original graph a and c do
not but in the inflation graph a and 2
and c do so now i can say there's a
monomial about my original properties
which shows up as a marginally inflation
graph
all right what else do i know about my
inflation graph um i know that there is
certain symmetries because a1
uh is really indistinguishable from a2
um as far as b is concerned
right not as far as c is concerned
because c is connected to a2 and it
shares a common parent what they do
whereas c does not share a common parent
with a1 but as far as b is concerned
you can take a1 and a2 switch the labels
and it's the same graph
all right it's the same calls and so
this gives me a sort of symmetry
constraint which is that the the sub
marginal over a1 a2 and b
if i take the value of a1 and i call it
a little one and a little two i can flip
those two values and it should be stable
under that sort of relabeling
that's a symmetry constraint so
all of these constraints are just linear
constraints on the existence of a joint
distribution on the inflation graph
and then i can say okay based on that
there exists a joint distribution of the
inflation graph which has these
marginals and these symmetries what does
that mean i can then just pull it out
and it's linear programming and this
gives me a linear program so
in summary um we say there exists a
distribution over the inflation graph
which recovers um that monomial which
recovers this monomial which recovers um
sort of a symmetry constraint we pull it
back um and we end up with an inequality
and this is inequality on the original
distributions because everything that
sort of went into this were monomials of
original probabilities
and so we've now extracted a inequality
which is a linear combination it's a
linear inequality on monomials which is
to say it's a polynomial
and that's how inflation works um
and so we get this inequality and it
tells us that here's an example of a
distribution which is imagine that zero
zero zero occurs and one more occurs
each with one f probability and nothing
else that can't happen uh because it's
certainly
[Music]
i would yes so that
people soon could understand so
um you mentioned that a2 is a different
version of a1 um
i just want to understand
how when you say that what it means i
think for statistical side maybe we
don't have that so we mean we mean that
um
uh
that
they're not only are they distributed
the same way
but then if you look at sort of their
their causal history
um at every stage
all of their ancestors are also
distributed in the same way and they
also combine in someone so the mechanism
by which a1 arises is the same mechanism
by which a2 arises from its recall
answer
yes
okay i'm sorry i just
your inflated graph has now four nodes
on it
um we normally think of the
the lambdas as entangled states right
well if we want if we made some uh
quantum in any case if we were thinking
of it that way then i can't actually get
all four data points on any single run
right
you you've preempted the whole point yes
exactly
okay
um so uh
the the reason inflation is useful
is because the the logic
is not quantum valid
uh if if if if we're trying to write
down quantum causal uh hypotheses using
sort of the language of causal
structures then inflation doesn't work
um okay um and and that's the whole
point which is we want to sort of find a
method which relies on
very much classical assumptions which
are not quantum valid assumptions and
sort of to see what are the implications
of the classical assumptions which then
lead us to these conclusions which
potentially might be quantum invalid
conclusions i quantum viable in the
quantities maybe this will help yeah
you're sort of thinking it's a classical
involving the possibility of a phone
a hundred percent okay
a hundred percent the whole point of
inflation is that if you want to get a
quantum value of inequality you take
your hidden variables and you broadcast
them
you climb them and if you if if your
logic goes through without cloning then
any conclusions you get from inflation
will be quantum valid and if your logic
goes through with cloning or
broadcasting then there's potential for
quantum violation which is the whole
point yes
exactly um so i wanted to then just um
uh upgrade a little bit of the
complexity to say that we can do
inflation sort of
more algorithmically as a hierarchy and
the idea here is instead of just
drawing an arbitrary inflation graph you
take
some set of your root variables in your
graph you copy them
so many times independently iid and then
you just watch what all the implications
are thereof so here i have three root
variables and in this version i have
taken the bc
root variable
made two copies of it and seen okay what
are all the implications of taking two
copies of the bc root variable so i have
now b1 and c1 and i have b2 and c2 and
of course here i've had to fan out
the source which now when originally
from ac now goes to a c1 and c2 and the
source that was originally a b now goes
ab1 and b2 um
uh the nice thing about this is that
instead of looking for symmetries of sub
graphs it's just the symmetry of the
whole graph which is that i can
relabel b1
c1 with b2c2 and the distribution where
all five random variables should be
invariant under that relabeling
and it leads to these kind of
constraints
the next version would be to consider
two of the root variables let's say the
bc source and the ac source and copy
them both twice
and then we get an inflation graph which
looks like this which now has eight
variables out of the inflation graph
but it's sort of all of the implications
of taking two copies of the ac source
and two copies of the bc source so we
call it inflation one two two right um
and uh
now we start seeing new sorts of
expressible monomials because we can
take a b c
times c
and we can express that as
the a1 b1 c11
and here there's this c22 which is has
no ancestry with it
and so we get these new uh
monomials that we can express um
[Music]
and then we can go to inflation two two
two which gets really uh ugly looking um
but it you know these are the monomials
that we can express some of them are
quadratic now we start having cubic
monomials that we can express um and
these are incredibly powerful just from
the fact that uh we take this graph we
say that it undergoes the appropriate
symmetries which is if you relabel one
of the sources let's say the ac source
the two versions it induces a relabeling
of all of the variables
and it should be stable under that relay
board so you assume that the
distribution over all the variables is
stable under such relabeling
and you can obtain these marginals
we can rule out
tons and tons of things so there's a
mark olivier renault was the first to
sort of come up with um an example which
has nothing to do with ball's theorem in
my opinion
of some quantum weirdness in the
triangle scenario and can we uh use sort
of any technique which is available
classical causal inference technique to
show that the distribution that
marklavian and someone behave came up
with is not compatible with triangle
it's really hard to do so but this will
do it
yes
so now to tim's point
when we derive inequalities
are they always possible to violate them
in quantum mechanics so here was an
inequality that arrived from very a very
simple inflation graph um and the
question is can we repeat the arguments
if we treat the sources the the hidden
variables as quantum entanglement uh and
as tim pointed out um if we make these
assumptions so now i'm using green and
psi as opposed to red and lambda um uh
can we make such a good noggin
experiment is it sensible and is tim
pointed out no it's not because that
would involve
broadcasting and
one of the fundamental
things which is true in quantum physics
is we cannot broadcast quantum states so
if there's this kind of fan out which is
a hidden variable had so many children
and now it has more children this is an
operation which is classically valid
quantumly it's invalid and so this is
why we're starting to get uh invalid
conclusions but we can repeat it with um
uh
different versions of inflation's which
don't involve this sort of fan out
structure
and so like this is the cut
and i wanted to just point out that
any time we have a fan out inflation we
can find non-phantom inflations as
subgraphs within so here is like the one
two one inflation of the triangle and if
you follow sort of the green and only
the green that is not fan out and so we
can then look at the sub graph on a b1
c2 which is exactly the one on the
previous line this abc is the cut
and similarly we can go forth and we can
say oh look here's another inflation of
the triangle
um
it's a non-phantomization does this show
up it shows up as a sub graph here
all right
so
the last thing i wanted to talk about is
if you're familiar with inflation
already and this was not surprising you
might want to say well the causal
structures that i'm interested in are
not just the triangle scenario i want to
deal with causal scenarios which have
more directed edges which are more
complicated
how ellie should we deal with causal
structures which have directed edges so
let's
go to a causal structure which has a
directed edge here's the instrumental
scenario with drawn in notation xav
and so we can
come up with a quantum version here
and so this is the idea of a single
world intervention graph swig
it's in another paper which i call
quantum inflation referred to as
interruption
and the idea is you take your original
graph over x a b and then you have this
new graph where there is no edge from a
to b instead there's another version of
a which has absolutely nothing that's
called the past and that points to b and
so this is a totally different scenario
but the distributions which are
compatible with this which we can
characterize it's easier um they do
relate to that one because if
the
the intervened version is set to little
a and we're also considering that this a
ends up taking the same value
then
it ends up being a probability in that
graph
um and so if you're familiar with single
word and written graphs this is
familiarity but this is a quantum valid
operation if we wanted to do a classical
analysis we don't have to do interrupts
we have to look at swigs we can just do
fan out so we could say oh that's the
original instrumental scenario let's
consider
taking two copies of x
so we have now fanned out we have
inflated x because x is a root variable
and we've taken two copies of x
and we have kept one copy of the a b
latent variable so this is like the in
for the
instrumental scenario this would be
inflation level two one where two copies
of x one copy of the a b source um and
now it's fanned out
and uh look
the original distribution over x a b
shows up but
x also is then independent of the error
so we have a monomial which is
expressible and if we run this through
we can derive inequalities
so this is an inflation perspective on
how to derive instrumental inequalities
but there's another way of doing it
which is instead of just taking copies
we can introduce a new kind of node
which is a
but it's not all a it's a
when x was set to zero so this is the do
conditional version of it
and this might be a different version of
a which is a when x is equal to one
and now we can use both of those to
induce the fanouts
um
uh by saying that the hidden variable
has to tell us what a should be when x
is zero what a should be when x is one
and we can use these to derive
inequalities um so let's move on to
another version
here is the unrelated confounders graph
which
robin evans came up with in one of his
papers
[Music]
if we want to derive inequalities on
this with inflation
we want to derive quantum value we want
to have quantum invalid inequalities
what do we do if we're interested in
quantum valid inequalities we do this
interruption and we look at the swig
and we can relate the original uh
probabilities to
certain conditional probabilities over
here
but this idea of interruption it doesn't
capture the independence of the a b
source from the bc source so this
captures e-separation if you're familiar
with that concept like if you if you
just run this as a linear program you
will find inequality constraints which
are implied but we can find stronger
ones if we can find some way of imposing
that it's not just that b is in the
middle but that there's these two
independent sources and to do that we
take two copies just two copies of the
original scenario and now what inflation
will tell us is that
we can relate
monomials of the original distribution
namely two original copies two marginals
or
conditionals in the inflation graph here
and it's the appropriate symmetry so if
we consider sort of um
the marginal in where we've traced out b
b1 and b2
then i can swap c1 and c2
by symmetry because that's just
relabeling this source with this source
which captures the idea that if we trace
out b1 and b2 that a and c are
independent and so the point here is
that symmetry of the
distribution over the inflation graph is
a proxy for independence and so
independence is nonlinear symmetry is
linear but we can impose symmetry and
simulate independence or or the
constraints which like it here is a
classical version for the uh unrelated
confounder scenario
where this is sort of like a natural
version of inflation
i haven't done any kind of interruption
and so i've considered two copies of
each of the sources and that induces now
four versions of a because there's the a
which sees
this source but sees the b which sees
this source and then there's the a which
sees the same source but c is a
different b namely the b that was
connected to this source so this is why
if you take two copies of three
variables you could end up with many
copies of some of the late children in
the graph
[Music]
so
as i'm finishing here
i've done this idea of introducing a
swig and not introducing a swig what's
the point when do we when do we
interrupt the graph and when do we not
and the point is we do this interruption
technique or we go to swigs if we're
trying to get quantum valid inequalities
or if we're trying to do mediation
analysis classically um
but if we're not doing mediationalists
if we're just doing calls compatibly
there's no reason to do it um
i guess i'll skip a bit because we're
out of time
this is just a version of a swig for the
unrelated confounding scenario so if we
did uh just do this interruption and
then the inflation then we have only two
versions of a so is this a quantum or a
classical operation well it's co it's
classical because we've done fan out
but it's not as classical as it could be
because it's only a three-way fan out as
opposed to a four-way phantom if we
expanded and demanded that c should
respond for each of the values of b
all right um and so then we have the
idea of prosper
okay um in summary there are three ways
to extend inflation to
uh
the case of directed edges there's the
version which i would endorse which is
actually the in the original paper from
2016
which is just follow them out if you've
got your uh
your causal structure take your root
nodes take multiple copies
find all the uh implications which
follow to the causal descendants um and
run the sort of usual symmetry and
expressible sets um
there's a version which um uses single
world intervention graphs this is
uh advocated in a paper called quantum
inflation um it's fine it's it's if
we're doing sort of if the goal is to
derive classical inequalities you could
do this uh i just think it's uh somewhat
wasteful um
cross-roll of inflation is the idea
which um we call the unpacking in my
paper with miguel
where we take uh we get rid of all the
directed edges by taking um each
variable and looking at its new
conditional for all of the cases of its
observed parents and then
anytime we move away from the natural
inflation we have this uh
feature bug i don't know that um
if you have a set uh of variables
potentially subsets of variables might
not be expressible so you might find
that like um uh
there's a version of b and is a version
of c inflation graph and you want to
know what's the marginal of b and c that
corresponds to a probability that you
know but if you just take b by itself
uh or c by itself it might not be a
responsible probability of b now whereas
if you're doing sort of natural
inflation those kind of things don't
show up
so the very last thing i'll mention is
a particularly challenging
graph that
robin put in one of his papers which is
from figure 14
is this dag saturated or not are there
constraints on the distribution of abc
so we could use inflation and we will
and have used inflation to derive
inequality constraints here um
and i wanted to point out two nice
features about this one is that if we
wanted to do a quantum analysis
we could go to the swig
and we would note that in this
particular graph
the due conditional c2a is an
identifiable new conditional
so when we go to the swig and we start
writing down uh some inflation like a
ring-like version of 14a and we want to
know what are the monomials that we can
express well we have
the usual versions that we can express
these are just products of conditionals
but we have also
these
which are
uh
perhaps not obvious um but they follow
from the fact that in this graph there
are due conditionals which are not just
um
based on exogenous variables so
when you have identifiable conditionals
which are not based on uh
exogenous variables you can use them in
inflation to an advantage if we're doing
natural inflation and this is the last
slide um
we get to use uh
fancier types of monomials so here
consider the dc source having two copies
and so we can consider a version where
um there's this d which looks at one
version of the source and there's c
which looks at a different version of
the source so i'll call it d version one
c version two this might show up in a
larger inflation graph here
what do we know about monomials that we
can express well we have abc
um
that sort of subgraph matches
abd matches but in fact the entire abcd
distribution here is identifiable
not just the three variable subgraphs
even though it's not the original graph
and that's because in this graph in the
inflatable graph you have that d1 and c2
are deseparated by a and b
and so all you need is that you can
identify the a b d
the a b c a b by itself and now you get
sort of this
new kind of expressible set um and
in order to show that um this graph 14a
is not saturated we can do it in
inflation level
uh one two two as it were um but to do
it at a low inflation level we have to
take advantage of these kinds of uh
more general expressible sets so that's
a lot i know um here are the references
um the first three are sort of like uh
lay out the different attitudes and i
would sort of
en encourage people to take a look at
the later two um mark olivier is going
to mention one of them which is if we
wanted to do non-founded inflation uh
and only non-finalization to derive
quantum value constraints there's a
hierarchy which allows us to do that
and
this was a paper where miguel proved
that the inflation technique converges
if you consider like
many many copies of the sources and pull
the linear program back eventually the
constraints on the monomials are
indistinguishable from the actual
compatible set
so there's a new very simple proof
of that fact which i really enjoyed and
it's fresh out of new york
thank you very much ellie it's really
interesting are there any questions for
ellie
two very quick questions your second
last slide of the graph on it
yeah so that looks the thing on the
right looks quadratic in the observed
distribution so right
the constraint you've got on the bottom
um
is that different from the things you
had before just i'm just saying that
i don't think it's really quadratic um
because if you if you wanted to make it
unconditional it would just be that the
probability of ac
and the probability of ac which is a
[Music]
monomial can be expressed um
okay sorry okay maybe i should probably
okay the the other question was you had
some inflations which were green and the
others that were red for example you see
quantum analysis yes and is that
structurally defined or is is it
semantics you're putting that yeah
so so the green versus the red is i um
when i'm doing the inflation if i'm
making one of these operations which
involves fan outs which is to say uh um
there was a child of the latent variable
which now there's multiple versions of
that child and we're sending the late
the a version of the of the late
variable to all of its children then i'm
using red because that's sort of the
classical case and i'm following robin's
color notation for mdx
green is sort of the color i'm using for
quantum and so if uh if the fanout
inflation does not involve
if the inflation does not involve any
kind of fanouts then
i'm using green because it
let's calm down
anywhere else yes
question from zoom from marina antonelli
in one of the last slides you said that
interruption is used to find quantum
valid inequalities
but what about the use of interruption
to go from instrument from the
instrumental scenario to bell and show
the qc gap in the instrumental scenario
yep that's a
that's a good question so um
we can uh
this is this is sort of what marine is
referring to so if we do interruption um
to the uh instrumental scenario we end
up with this graph which involves four
variables which is
essentially the same as the ball graph
so everything we know about the bar
graph we can just apply the constraints
here and that shows us this link between
uh bell inequalities and instrumental
inequalities if you know all the bone
equalities you can figure out all the
instrumental inequalities um
uh and that that's true uh and that sort
of goes through at the level of all
physical theories which is is the point
right it doesn't assume classicality um
but if our goal here is to derive
new inequalities here
um
for this graph
if we had no knowledge of bone
inequalities
then in order to derive bell
inequalities we would need to um if we
wanted to do it strictly with inflation
we would need to do fan that we need to
consider a for both versions of x
or b for both versions of a either way
and that would take us beyond sort of
single world intervention graphs and
take us into these sort of cross world
intervention graphs
okay excellent then let's thank ellie
again and
the next talks at 10 40 is that right